music ultimately is a global medium and
we want to connect the world
through this expressive medium
we don't think there's anybody out there
that doesn't like
me
smells a leader in mobile social music
we'd like a billion people to figure out
how to make music together using mobile
devices that's one of the reasons why
we're extremely excited about the
Android platform we were amazed at how
many more users we were able to reach in
such a short period of time we're now
north of 12 million monthly users
hitting our products and that compares
it's about two and a half million a year
ago before we were on Android and Google
Play
it's record growth it's the fastest
growth we've ever seen we have over 10
million installs now and that's been
only about three months 80% of our users
for songify are outside of the US
markets like Russia and Brazil and India
and Malaysia autorap was the first app
that we launched simultaneously across
platforms and we were amazed with what
we saw not only did it allow us to reach
more people there was incredible
word-of-mouth growth there was this halo
effect we spent a lot of time trying to
create landing pages and images and
marketing materials that allow customers
to quickly understand what our apps
deliver and get excited about it and
then install the application when
customers install our apps from a
YouTube video they tend to be two to
three times more valuable they are more
engaged they stay for longer and they
monetize better I think
Auto app has been a great example of how
the ability to update immediately has
really helped us with our product
quality our rating for our app has been
consistently higher every single day
basically since we've launched on Google
Play and that's directly a result of the
fact that we can respond immediately and
when when a bug comes up and
for getting certain feedback from users
we can fix that in it in a day and
launch it we want to bring music back to
its roots of a social interactive
expressive medium and that can only
happen if we bring everybody with us and
that's one of the reasons why we're so
excited about Android and Google Play we
think we open up this experience to the
growth through this platform